[Music]
we're gonna be talking about CSP and
hybrid identity today so it's a topic
that I'm very excited to share with you
guys so my name is Naveen chant I'm a
product manager I work on GCP identity
today I'll be joined with my esteemed
colleague Renault who is an engineer
working on GCP identity as well
we talked or we introduced anthos two
days ago which is the latest innovation
in hybrid multi cloud that allows you to
modernize your applications automate
policy provide security at scale which
and have your applications run anywhere
either on-premise or in any cloud now at
the center of a lot of these scenarios
is really identity in order to be able
to achieve these true hybrid cross cloud
cross-platform type of capabilities the
strong notion of identity is required
both for policy as well as seamless
access across these different systems
and so in today's talk will be walking
through a deep dive in a couple of
specific use cases around hybrid
identity
starting with GCP hybrid identity and
Beyond Corp will then talk a little bit
about authentication inside of
kubernetes getting into things like
workload identity on how you can
actually go start using workloads that
exist in different systems get access
across without having to do things like
key exchanges or downloading specific
user keys secure um service keys and the
final thing that we'll talk about today
is really around sto identity so to tee
it up GCP and hybrid identity along with
Beyond Corp now the first thing is
really when working in a hybrid
environment you need to get your users
to get access to GCP and so after you've
created your organization one of the
first things to do is to go and start
figuring out how to grant your
developers the rest the folks that
actually need access to the environment
permissions and so to grant access we
use something called Google Cloud
identity which is who a Google service
that allows customers to create and
manage users as well as groups in order
to grant them access to cloud resources
now in addition to granting access to
GCP Google cloud identity is also a
standalone offering has Ida's
capabilities that allows it to do things
like for bus lifecycle management device
policies provisioning of users across a
multitude of different applications if
your identities are actually reside in
an on-prem just like this example shows
you can synchronize it using a tool
called Google Cloud Directory
synchronization or GCPs for short this
tool allows you to select the specific
users using LDAP across either an LDAP
filter to select which set of users you
want to bring in or select the set of
use that you have in order to pull those
identities in in order to configure
single sign-on
you can use sam'l either in this case
using an ad FS instance or any really
Federation token broker that allows you
to take identities from your on-prem
system present a sam'l assertion that
can be used in order to grant them
single sign-on into GCP if your company
happens to use one of these other
identity platforms many of them have
capabilities built-in that allow you to
do things like provision users and do
configure the single sign-on directly
with GCP already next we're going to
talk a little bit of a Beyond Corp now
starting in 2011 who will introduced a
new approach to how to do access
management which was called beyond Corp
security this is beyond Corp security
model it's a zero trust security model
and what that means is you don't rely on
the permissions or specific Network
configurations or making sure somebody
has to reside on your corporate network
in order to gain access but instead it
verifies properties of the requester
making sure that this requester has
access and permissions to the specific
resources that they're gaining access so
it shifts the focus from using network
perimeter to individual users and
devices and using those in order to
decide whether or not somebody should
gain access and this allows employees to
work seamlessly regardless of where
they're located so we're gonna spend a
couple of minutes and look a little bit
closer into beyond Corp and how it can
be used in a hybrid environment
before we get there though just going a
little deeper into beyond Corp it has
four beyond Corp there's several
different components that are needed in
order to be able to make it to make up
the solution one is a notion of strong
user identity which and while it doesn't
require you to use phishing resistant
technology it definitely works very well
with that so you can use notions like
security keys in order to make sure that
the requester that's coming in is
actually accessing the location that
they need it also leverages context
information about the requests so things
like where the request is originating
from and in addition looks at things
like device posture to see what type of
device is actually this request actually
coming from as well using those two
types of information it pulls it into a
central centralized policy engine that
allows both IT teams to go defined these
types of policies that says only devices
that have the following security
postures and these specific class of
users can get access to this resource
and then uses a centralized enforcement
point in order to be able to ensure that
this type of access is consistently
administered regardless of where persons
coming in from so Google cloud provides
a solution for the beyond core product
and it's comprised of several different
products inside of Google one of which
is cloud identity that allows you to
take care of the identity as well as the
context information in terms of what
device is that this request actually
coming in from there's another component
around a rules engine and that's done
through access context manager that
allows you to go and look at information
around kind of origination of the
request device posture in order to make
that authentication and authorization
decision we also use vbc security
control service controls that improve
your ability to mitigate the risk of
data exfiltration from google managed
services things like cloud storage
bigquery you can actually do a boundary
around all these services to ensure that
all your data routines within those
those walls it also uses I am which is
Identity and Access Management that
allows you to specify granular controls
on resources to decide whether or not a
specific user should have access to that
resource
in the final piece is really cloud IEP
now cloud IP or identity where proxy is
a GCP service that provides
off-the-shelf authentication and
authorization for system asking for
applications that are deployed on GCP it
is also the starting point for many
customers to retire their legacy VPNs
and use Google's context to where access
story but while this works great for
scenarios that exist on Google fabric
the reality as many customers have
applications that actually run either in
an on-prem environment or in another
cloud so IEP also now supports the
ability to protect your workloads no
matter where they're located numerous
customers are now reading traffic that
actually goes through Google's front
ends leverages I ap and then forwards
the a cryptid traffic back to their
applications no matter where that
application is and the best part is
there are no changes to required to the
application it all happens right in
front of it adding a layer of protection
so we're gonna walk through this in a
little bit more detail when a user
actually connects in one of the things
that happens is the device posture and
device information is captured and
continuously updated in one of the
databases when a request comes into the
system GCL B provides Network layer
protection so it can do things like
protect it against DDoS attacks provides
TLS termination and also manages
certificates and allows you to configure
things like IP block lists the identity
where proxy uses the user identity as
well as the user identity as well as
device information in order to be able
to make access decisions in this case
you'll see a the I ap on Prem connector
which is the component that allows you
it's an open source tool that allows you
to connect to a on Prem back-end
resource one of the things that needs to
be done is for that on Prem application
need to configure the network policy so
that only requests that originate
through the I ap front-end system will
be able to get access in order to
Trulli deploy this model end to end once
that's configured the be on court model
works completely for these scenarios so
that was the first section talking a
little bit about how you can use GCP in
a hybrid environment where your users
are either configured in an external
identity source on Prem or coming from a
external iodized system talked a little
bit about beyond for now we're gonna
switch into kubernetes and then we'll
talk about how you can configure
authentication and authorization into
kubernetes clusters using your existing
enterprise infrastructure but that will
switch over to my colleague rena so in
this section we will be looking into how
to authenticate into the kubernetes
control plane for cluster management
activities so we'll focus on the usage
of the kubernetes api through the
standard command line interface or
clifford shirt which is called cube karo
and the same principles apply for two
other means of interacting with the
control plane in kubernetes for instance
if you use any of the controller UI's so
in this scenario that we're going to
look into here we have Jeannine as a
cloud engineer and she works for a
company called Zach Hicks she's just
finished creating their first kubernetes
cluster as Giannini went through the
steps to create the cluster those steps
gave her admin privilege which is
natural because she's just created the
cluster but it's based on secrets that
are stored in a cube config file
typically that's the outcome of creating
a kubernetes cluster through most of the
procedures but Zod kicks security
policies outlined a set of requirements
for access to produce production assets
and this requirements are not met by
secrets is stored in configuration files
in administrators you know laptops and
other devices so we need to find a
different solution that is Enterprise
compatible incompatible with security
posture of most enterprise
environments so indeed in most
enterprise environments integrating the
SSO infrastructure is required to manage
the production workloads so this
involves two two steps effectively one
is to connect the authentication and the
credential management to the SSO system
and the order is to configure
permissions based on the centrally
managed groups so we'll look into each
of this steps in detail
well first what is available in
kubernetes today so kubernetes supports
several mechanisms to authenticate into
a cluster but for integration with the
SSO systems kubernetes supports in
particular OpenID Connect which also
known as oh I DC and Active Directory
Federation services or ad FS for short
is a commonly deployed enterprise system
part of the Active Directory set of
services and it implements an open and
open ad connect provider identity
provider or IDP so this provides a means
for us to enable enterprise single
sign-on into a cluster you know I'm
assuming in this talk that we're using
ad FS we're going to go into some
configuration details here but many
other enterprises are so solutions such
as Google cloud identity the Google
Cloud identity platform as your ad octa
or support o IDC so now I'm for we're
going to show a demo on how to register
our district line for ad FS so here we
have the panel for Active Directory
management we have a handy set of notes
and we have a PowerShell I hope it looks
better from there so first I add an
application group am i giving it a hint
a name and I will make it a server
application type
I need to choose a client identifier
that is a little more I remember
easily recalled because the one that
gets generated is random so it just
makes painful to copy and paste but I'll
copy it in here I remember it as my
client ID next I need to have a register
redirect URL I should first choose the
port that is widely available in my
enterprise environment and then I can
register IRL that points that port the
reason is that we need a place to
redirect the token after the
authentication to the users workstation
and here we caught also the client
secret that gets out of generated when
we enable secret up based authentication
so I finished creating an open addict
client in a DFS but now I need to
configure a groups token groups rule
which allow me to share groups
information from Active Directory with
the club and kubernetes cluster so we
can do a role based access control so I
have to give it you know some
descriptive information so I can
remember it but the important thing here
is also that I need to authorize later
to grant us essentially permissions for
ID FS to share that information to this
specific to kubernetes client that I
registered in the first step so I
created the rule now I'm actually saying
what I'm gonna populate it with what is
going to be propagated by that rule and
what I'm will configure this is to use
LDAP groups it's called the token groups
so I'm using token groups qualified by
long domain name which gives the
greatest security because you can't have
collisions that way and I'm naming the
output
the token as groups that's gonna be the
claim name in the token and I'm
remembering all of this information
because I'm gonna have to configure my
client as well as well as the API server
to be able to understand how to process
the token information so finally that
now that I finished creating the
configuration of the client and of how
to share the group's claims I need to
grant authorization to the client that I
created to receive groups information so
that's the last command that I'm gonna
run in the Windows PowerShell as an
administrator and we are done with this
first step and if you have a different
ID P ahktar something clouded in the
platform Google Cloud identity you are
going to have a different set of steps
to configure the identity provider but
most of the subsequent steps in this
conversation here will be generic for
any provider so we have now some handy
notes that we took during our client
registration with the parameters for the
widest OpenID connect client that we
registered but the cube Caudill Clee
near the command line interface also
needs those parameters to integrate with
the IDP but in addition to the
information about the client base code
the widest C client cube kata also needs
some information about the provider
itself such as where is the provider so
we will show how to get that information
from a DFS okay so here what there are
two pieces of information that I need
about the provider itself for my cube
color configuration one is where is the
provider so I'm going to start trying
I'm here at the ad FS server and it has
the host information has the domain
information so that gives me the domain
part of this URL and next I'm going to
look into the ad endpoint configuration
for ad FS because ad FS has many
endpoints that serve different
properties
I look at the open ID connect endpoints
and what is important is there is
something that starts with dot
well-known the part of the path before
that is where they DFS instances so I
got that section of the part a path is
very typically just a DFS ah and now I
want to get this certificate
so I'm looking into this certificate
that the ad FS server uses because the
kubernetes cluster is not part of my
domain and it doesn't know the
intermediate certificates that I have
deployed in my services such as a DFS so
I'm going through the certificate to AH
and I am going to export the
intermediate certificate that is used by
the IDF s server so I've just used the
export wizard and I had chosen a file
name so I'm going to use that and we are
finished with the parameters from the
issuer okay so now we have the OST
client parameters and we have the issuer
parameters now we go to the API server
we need to configure the API server to
actually accept signings from this
Odyssey client that we created so this
involves restarting the API server with
a set of flags that enable YDC
authentication so this I had from my
handy notes that I took while I did the
previous two demos and this is showing
to how I can configure the flags with
those parameters and if I start the API
server with those parameters it will be
unable to accept it will be able to
accept or you see authentication now we
are finally ready to prepare cube
Caudill to authenticate to the cluster
and cubic kado remember it needed a
receipt client parameters that we
registered with a DFS it needed some
server parameters that we got from the
ad FS configuration itself
but it also needs some parameters from
the cluster so it knows how to talk to
it okay so that's the last set of
parameters that we need to finish this
so recall that right after Jeanine
created the cluster
she had a usable configuration that gave
her admin privileges in the cast in the
cluster so data from that configuration
actually has all the cluster parameters
that we mean so we are gonna go look
into that file the cube config file that
was initially created to get those
parameters so that we can package all of
this in a single file that will make it
much easier for all the other
administrators I'll as well as the other
users developers in the cluster to be
able to authenticate so let's see how we
can package all this metadata so we have
created a a plugin to facilitate users
to sign in today to get access to it
you'll need to sign in for the GK on
Prem offering but if you in the future
plan to make it more widely available so
once you download this plug-in you make
it as acute able and if you are moving
to a part two a path a location in your
path it would be available for cube
Karam so now I have collected in this
file all the parameters from the three
steps that I went before and I
configured them as a single command
which is cube kado Oh Ida C is the name
of our plugin that was just installed
and client configs the name of the
parameter once we once we've run we need
to a couple of the parameters that I
explained from the cluster itself so now
I open that early cube config file and I
found this server name okay and I'm back
to that file the server your location
the server name and I need the server
certificate authority so I gave it a
name and I'm gonna export from there the
this was the certificate that was in bad
in this original cube gymkata config
file and I'm gonna basically base64
decoded into a certificate file so now I
have everything ready so you have a
properly formatted certificate store I
have all the parameters I can run that
command and I have a file and so that is
work that is completely configured with
client information oh I do see is your
information and cluster information that
cube Caudill needs to be able to
authenticate so this was a lot of steps
you definitely don't want more than one
administrator to have to go through this
so that's why we created this plugin
this plug in plug wraps all the
parameters in one easy file and now you
can distribute this file to all the
users in your organization ok so let's
see how we can actually use this file to
enable all users in the in the
organization to easily sign in with a
Panetta connect ok and so we are again
using the same plugin but now the login
command I chose a username for myself I
passed the config file that the
administrator sent to me and I chose a
cube config name where I store my cube
config information so I'm signing in
using the ID FS and signing page that's
it that's a user experience and they are
ready to go so now you have everything
starting this cube config file I'm going
to set up as my environment variable so
I can now just could start performing
operations of the cluster and I'm
authentic ated using single sign-on and
leveraging kubernetes authorization so a
lot of steps for the first administrator
extremely easy for other administrator
or users later once that file is back
you just have to run that's the that's
all okay let's look allow a little more
into how communities are back
works because we figured out how to
authenticate now how do we grant
privileges the cluster so suck ticks
again bring him back to the to their
perspective wants to segment privileges
within the cluster so one situation
could be that they require a strict
separation between production and
development work clothes so components
allows you to compartmentalize
permissions in this way through
namespaces and administrators can
delegate permissions to a namespace
permissions can be attached to a role
and there are two types of roles in
kubernetes our back one is a role with
cluster wide scope that's called a
cluster row anyone a role that has
namespace wide scope and that's just
called row rows can be granted to users
and groups using bindings okay so a
cluster row binding binds a cluster role
to a user or a group and the binding has
a scope across a cluster wide a row
binding on the other hand can bind
either a cluster row or a role to a user
or a group but the binding has main
space scope in the next demo will show
how as up kicks' administrator can use
bindings to grant roles to users and
groups so I will now show a demo of how
to set up the kubernetes er back I can
see my ad I have two users one is Brenna
and if you look at the properties here
is part of a group called cluster admin
okay but we also have another user
called unprivileged and as we would
expect here is not a member of any group
except domain users okay so I am
logged in to cube cuddle as myself using
my plugin as before and I'm gonna get
cluster roles for this cluster there's a
bunch of them and I see one called
cluster admin that looks suggested
so let's look find more about that
cluster role so I am going to expect the
cluster rule called cluster admin and I
see that it is a cluster row the name is
cluster admin and it is granted a lot of
privileges okay it can do every
operation on every resource on every API
group in the communities API great who
can actually use that exercise that
cluster role well I see I also a row
binding called cluster admin maybe
that's the one I'm looking for
let's look at this cluster admin row
binding okay
it is our cluster row binding the name
is cluster admin and it refers to the
root to the cluster all cluster admin
that I had before so it looks all
promising but the subject is a system
object that doesn't sound like the right
cluster oh I would expect users groups
coming from ad in that setting so I'm
going back to my list of row bindings
and I found something else called
cluster manager is that the right one
let's look at what the cluster manager
has it looks very similar but the main
difference is that the subject is the
white the group called cluster admin
coming from the SSO environment so
that's indeed the cluster the binding
that is granting me privileges so you
perform all these operations okay now
I'm gonna try and do the same as the
unprivileged user okay and if I remand
this operation I can see that instead of
looking at the cluster roles I'm getting
that the user you know with the long
name qualified there cannot list
resources cluster roles okay because
they are not a part of the cluster admin
group and therefore they are not bound
to the cluster manager role in the
cluster now I will go we talked quite a
bit about user authentication I will
talk about workload identity now so
workload identity in kubernetes there is
a pre built-in system for workload
Edinson kubernetes when we use the
kubernetes api in this form of a
kubernetes identity is called a service
account and it's created in a namespace
so kubernetes service service accounts
may be granted permissions either via
cluster role bindings or ro bindings
just as users and groups so in this
example I'm showing here how jenkins
recipe sorry CI CD workload can be
granted permission to modify all pods in
a cluster it also shows how the same
permission can be great so if you look
here can you see there I don't see my oh
well sorry I don't see the pointer so
I'm just going to point it directly you
have a cluster or corporate leader which
is given permissions to modify pods in
the cluster and it is but we have a
cluster role binding that binds this
privilege to a service account called CI
CD which is your continuous deployment
to and so naturally as you there cause
continuous deployment to needs to update
jobs in the cluster and so use the
granting C refers to the cluster whole
pod updater
so this allows a workload that's running
in the cluster with this service
identity which
runs in the production in space and with
named CI CD to modify our pods in the
cluster there is a separate row binding
here that gives to the dev team the
ability to exercise also this pod update
a rule but only in the namespace
development and so if you that you have
a production job they will not be able
to modify it we now have support for
workload identity in GK to directly
exercise privileges in GCP I am so that
makes it much easier to secure access to
your disappear sources because you no
longer need to download and manage the
piece service accounts in GK
instead you can with workload identity
the provision of credentials for GK
services can be fully managed so if you
look at the parallel here in kubernetes
are back if you wanted to create to
grant privileges you create a cluster
role and Euclid crust cluster role
bindings where you grant those rows
privileges to those roles privileges to
specific users or groups or service
accounts in GCP I am our back you
similarly you have a service account
just a piece service account and what
you do is you grant this service account
access to some properties in your
project so here I'm granting this
disappea service account an editor role
in a project then you can exercise that
role from a kubernetes workload by
adding a policy binding that mentions a
copy a workload identity in decay
okay so that's what this expression is
describing here if you recall from the
example that we gave the namespace
production and the service account CI CD
represented my continuous deployment -
so with this configuration you don't
need to create a download the key into
your GAE deployed to it can directly
access disappea okay and this courtesy
to our friends in the GAE team I have a
demonstration how this works first we
are creating your works cluster there is
a flag called identity namespace that
tells us that they should enable the
workload the identity feature in the
cluster so we're looking at the
configuration here I have an app called
GCS server and it has an annotation
which refers to a disappea service
account so that extends you tells our
metadata service - how to allow the
workload identity to get tokens to talk
to disappea and this all happens
transparently with no changes to the up
to the application or the provision of
credentials is using the infrastructure
of decay so then they just for reference
we have the namespace and service
account they were called identity
service account there we are creating
that disappear service account we refer
to in the annotation
and we are saying that the application
that we Kris constructed is now running
is deployed we want to grant the binding
that I talks about where we give the
kubernetes service account the ability
to impersonate the disappea service
account to exercise that role whoops
something is not working what could
possibly go wrong
we forgot to grant actually privileges
so I was just at this service account
that I just created
okay so it is successful impersonating
the disappear service account but this
just is different account has no
privileges so we can fix that
in a minute you'll see how to fix that
okay the error is access denied so we
are indeed you see you mentioned there's
just a piece service account so the
error of was so now we add the
permission see that's echo and we gave
read the privileges to our just to be a
service account formation and now the
job is able to accept to perform its
operations correctly fetch the results
and display them and this is showing
that this is a motocross motor cluster
feature you can enable the same the same
identity in the same role be used by
multiple clusters okay
and so we are deploying the server in a
different you can see East can access
and so can West alright they both can
access your GCS resource and if however
if you delete that echo or the icon the
service accounts you can see that the
application no longer can access the
same resource and you go back to that
scenario where you don't have privilege
okay so with that finishes our
demonstration of workload identity
incumbent
and now I'm gonna give you an overview
of identification in a hybrid
environment so astillero
is an open source mesh that layer in
spirals transparently only existing and
distributed services and is also a
platform including API is the let
integrate with any logging telemetry or
policy system so why should we use
consider using Sto in my hybrid
environment so it still makes it easy to
create a network of deployed services
with a load balancing services service
authentication monitoring and more with
few or no code changes in service code
and it also can be used to deliver
secure service to service communication
in a cluster with the strong identity
based authentication authorization based
on mutual TLS and Google is a major
contributor of today's to development
and architecture so it means that by
using Co you take advantage of some of
the best practices and strategies for
micro service mass management so to
begin you still support two services by
deploying a sidecar proxy throughout
your environment and this sidecar proxy
intercepts all network communication
between the micro services one then can
configure and manage istoo through its
control plane functionality so it allows
zot kicks in this case to distribute
policy throughout this damask as well as
telemetry configuration audit policy of
network accessibility rules and so on
and configuration is consumed by others
and VoIP proxies both the an ingress
proxy of present as well as the sidecar
proxies and it's the policy
is enforced by the infrastructure so in
particular why to you why you should use
the steel security because it delivers
authentication authorization audit as
part of the platform so you don't need
to burden your application developers
with getting that right and in addition
you get consistence a consistent
application of those policies so it much
easier to a complete compliance
activities in within your environment ok
so let's give an example scenario where
that kicks is trying to use you to
provide access management to their own
premises applications in this example
it's deployed in the g/km parent cluster
in particular kubernetes cluster but it
still can also be used to protect our
workloads in more traditional on-premise
data centers that are not based on
communities so here when the Corp user
of the corpus is authenticated using
credentials on the Corp environment and
they make a request let's say to the sod
kicks HR application they end in grass
proxy will terminate the TLS connection
and we force at the request includes
user credentials later as the request
travels down the stack you can have
policy being applied at every hop so for
instance if you accessing a method that
requires administrative privileges the
sidecar envoy can require that you have
those privileges because they are you
belong to a particular group privileged
group that has the ability to perform
their operation and in between hops you
still can leverage both the initial
requesting user identity as well as the
peer identity perform a thorough zation
here we see a scenario where the
employee is accessing from an overseas
location ok so
in this scenario shot kicks decided to
use the identical web proxy I a P to
take advantage of Google's fast Network
globe-spanning network so it's many of
our customers actually use IP to route
both traffic to their cloud applications
as well as on-premises applications
because of the advantage of the Google
Network connectivity and by using a ap
in addition you get access to the
context aware of the ization rules that
IP provides for instance you can
configure that some operations require
second factor authentication or so that
the device is in a good state now let's
look at how the subtext can use the same
architecture to protect their cloud apps
they having extended the identity system
to disappear by using cloud identity by
leveraging the identity of web proxy
they have authentication authorization
at ingress which simplifies the
management for the applications and here
in this scenario we showed that this can
you be used to protect a legacy
application such as a database VM in
running in JCP employees also can have
access to their GAE apps controlled this
way again similar consistent view
between the on-premise our setting and
the cloud setting by leveraging sto and
I ap in addition to protecting employee
based authentication you can use the
this infrastructure to protect your
consumer-oriented applications the same
architecture and one of the advantages
here is that authentication
authorization and audits they permeate
the entire service stack which reduces
trust between sis
you don't need to trust the assertion of
the user identity from the front end in
the back end you can remove this amount
of in service to service trust which
facilitates compliance against
requirements audit requirements and it
also just reduces inside the risk
another feature of this architecture is
that it has a strong sense of peer
identity by using mutual TLS you can
have strong assurances about the peer
that is connected so here in the cases
app back-end you have a very strong
confidence that it's the request indeed
comes from its front end
so finally we go back to what we talked
about earlier with workload identity you
can enable workload identity in GAE and
now have a fully managed credential
credentials for your workloads where you
can directly grant access to I am to
your workload identity and you also make
it much easier and secure to consume
energy CP services such as cloud store
or stack drive driver pro metrics in
this scenario stack driver is providing
the metrics a telemetry infrastructure
for sto so tying you together we can see
that in a hybrid environment doc techs
can leverage both open sources to
architecture and Google managed services
such as IEP and stack driver in a well
integrated environment that delivers
consistent transparent and auditable
policy enforcement and in addition
through the integration of workload
identity with I am Jacques techs can
seamlessly consume disappear services
from the educates with improved security
and eliminating the need to manage
credentials so let's recap summing up we
have seen that CSP and GCP provide
robust capabilities to help you easily
con
to your existing eye dentist solutions
this capabilities enable you to
uniformly manage hybrid applications
with GK and Sto and they allow you to
easily secure your hybrid applications
your hybrid environment and you can make
your applications available anywhere
securely by leveraging beyond Korb
technology
[Music]